hello and welcome to the fifth annual
meeting of the tallahassee black
republicans
now i'm pissed royally pissed
last november barack obama was
re-elected president
and the black vote went almost entirely
to him
we're not getting our message out
obviously
the republican party is and should be
the only home
for black voters yes sir now people
think
that black voters are a monolith we're
not a monolith
what no we're not in fact black
republicans alone are an extremely
diverse group of people
now to speak more on diversity i present
tonight's speaker
mr douglas jackson
no i'm not gonna sugarcoat it i'm pissed
i am royally pissed
the liberal media thinks that
republicanism is not for black
people now you tell me what about fiscal
responsibility
a strong national defense and limited
government is unappealing
to black people we're not a monolith
we come in all different shapes and
sizes we do
now who here like to come up to this
podium and speak about the diversity
amongst black republicans
gentlemen we have a real treat today a
gentleman who is a little bit eccentric
a little bit outside of the box if you
will
but i can't think of a better person to
speak on diversity
amongst black republicans than this
gentleman right here all the way from
orlando my good friend
arthur washington
thank you for the induction brother
douglas thank you for being here brother
arthur
however i am pissed
royally pissed democrats think they have
a right to all the black people
but that is not the case we are not a
monolith
democrats may be cool but they ain't
practical there you go republicans are
practical
black people are practical come and
think of it
get those pants i think black
republicans are pretty cool
not to mention very diverse
excuse me gentlemen uh sorry to
interrupt
someone's white wife is here to pick
them up
was her name emily uh she was white okay
you